this isn't a joke by the way the the
organizers were like look we're doing a
show at Edge we want to end the show in
the edgiest fashion possible there is
nothing edgier than a white British
rapper so that's what we're going to do
I I specifically do freestyle rap that's
rap that you make up it's not written or
prepared we've got some fans there this
side as well they're getting into
it still some incredulous faces over
there still people going this is going
to be the worst [__] we've ever seen we
thought we were comeing over here to see
something spectacular not a white man
freestyle for this to work what I need
everyone here to do everyone right now
to start thinking of something you'd
like a wrap about but first there are
rules because this is British hip hop so
rules number one do not think of a food
or an animal it's too easy to rrap about
too obvious too boring anyone can say
dog and pizza and rap about that number
two nothing too obvious so don't say
anything I could have predicted you'd
say here don't just you know be boring
with it be creative and that's rule
number three have fun with your
suggestion be imaginative the best
example of this was a German man this is
how difficult you can be at a gig in
Hamburg I ask for a suggestion for a rap
and he goes yeah how about you do a rap
about the day in the life of an Aztec
high
priest let us see you do that
Englishman thank
you be as creative as clouse we'll take
five topics one from each kind of
perfectly constructed wedge then we'll
drop a beat and do a freestyle R we'll
start with this trunch here hello this
side what would you like a freestyle rap
about H Ed pills HS Ed
pills that was a woman that said that as
well time I put on Hulu with my family
please every time you put on Hulu with
your family it plays that well that
would suggest your father's being
targeted which
is you just look over on your mother's
nudging him like you have been a bit
floppy
recently for those of you that don't
understand the the acronym Ed erectile
dysfunction yeah cool Hy you don't work
you this isn't a lie to secretly get
advertising for them is it no sometimes
people do that they they name the
product they work for but him you're
smiling so broadly it makes me think
you've taken them as well and you're not
telling us
something the clitoris is made of
erectile tissue as well so theoretically
it would work you didn't need to get
that image but now you have
it sexy science suggestion number two is
coming from this segment here what would
you like a wrap about Disney adults okay
there were three so you said Disney
adults are you one sir I'm not you're
not and you said pediatrician are you
one Madam no no okay cool p a Disney
adult pediatrician that's what we'll
we'll take do you have a favorite Disney
film someone over there answered for you
someone just said poker Hunters what
what were you going to say I said Iron
Man you said Iron Man [__] off
that's technically yes but really no and
then person who said pediatrician do you
have a favorite childhood
[Laughter]
illness dentry that feels like a Heckle
directed at our country doesn't
it okay a Disney adult pediatrician
dealing with dentry middle middle of the
room and look I'm I'm hesitant to ask
this because British people are [__]
nightmares and they're they're just sat
there going oh we're going to shout out
David Beckham or samit but um this
section what would you like to wrap
about
woman so okay so you said Char fingers
Charles's fingers okay so in our country
we have what's called a king and he
you've not had one for a while he has he
has sausage fingers right and then what
did you say someone down here said
something name a
woman did you just say name a
woman that that's the suggestion for the
rap oh this is going to be hard ah [__]
um Christina Aguilera she's my don't
know why she's in my head um okay so
Charles's fingers maybe name a woman are
you all right do you know what's
happening here I didn't realize altitude
sickness started the 101st floor but
causes confusion for puzzlement uh this
section here what would you like to wrap
abouty G Wall Street okay
we I love that that someone over here
was ready to give one after we got the
excellent xylophone and the even better
gays on Wall
Street man was like oh I can beat that
no you
can't sorry xylophone gays on Wall
Street is
better great and then the final section
is the biggest one so let's hope this is
the best
suggestion so okay so there was a
feminine voice here did you say you said
Charlamagne all right [__] off and no
yeah Holy Roman Emperor Charlamagne dick
that's and wait
what and then okay
and what are you
saying Gypsy
Rose Gypsy Rose Blanchard is what she
said and you'll have to explain who that
is the fact that it's is this the answer
to name a
woman her mom she killed her
mom her boyfriend killed her mom why do
oh it's cuz all the women know it cuz
it's true crime that's why all the men
are like I thought that was the name of
my favorite stripper Gypsy
Rose so she killed her
boyfriend
recently she just was released from
prison okay this is less depressing than
it would be so her boyfriend killed her
mom because because there there's got to
be a
reason her mom made up all illnesses cuz
her mom made up illnesses m great Munch
mun by proxy Munch by proxy that's
[__] [__] to rhyme all
right and shut up if who said Steven
Hawking right this is what you've got
this is what you've asked for we've got
the gays on Wall Street maybe xylophone
Gypsy Rose Blanchard Charles's sausage
fingers perhaps naming a woman a
pediatrician treating dentry who's a
Disney adult and HS Ed pills and I am as
impressed as you that I remembered all
of those things
this is what we're going to
do we're going to drop that beat let's
get this going this is a freestyle that
is a rat made up on the spot were you
the Russian man from before no him I
wouldn't have guessed but okay cool I'm
exit what's your name Russian man GNA
GNA GNA how do you spell that g n a g n
a you said that as if I should know okay
and turn that up for me Ethan turn it
up this is going to be fun get
excited we start the show so good you'll
see again a front row Russian dude chest
ter he's called gner he's going to get
you if you're feeling insane I love it
he's got the watch strap yeah who can
blame he holds it up high look at this
all of yard he got the nice Swiss one
call it a sat in the front row like yeah
I'm the bloke I might spoil any lady
when I got my Royal out you best know
when you sat watching TV see your dad
over there saying you got Ed you need to
make sure you go through and through
advertise frequently on Hulu you say Dad
do you subscribe to HS in the mail SLE
mailing they provide no one even knows
yeah you give a toast thanks H when I
get my mail on my post nobody knows that
it makes my dick so hard stand up there
like I'm in charge can you picture your
dad's penis on the stage I know you
ain't seen it for an age it's not weird
when you're a child I might say this my
dad would frequent walk around the house
naked and I would say Dad I don't want
this I'm sat cross-legged trying to
watch poker
Hunters singing I sing yeah I paint with
all the colors of the wind see John
Smith and the poker Hunters native if I
was a Disney adult yeah I'd go crazy off
to Walt Disneyland Walt Disney World
people look at me and say you're not a
6-year-old girl name a girl name a woman
name a lady are you okay are you crazy
did poah hun us already we can do more
Christina aquera I said yes I know I
adore my favorite one of course the lady
you chose name a woman Miss Blanchard
Gypsy Rose she
was from prison recently her mother's
boyfriend did her indecently he was like
oh yes unlock me I feel the Rage rousing
that's Munch house I'm by
proxy KN maybe take a gun who thought
you'd applaud this one it's not fun all
the guys were like it's with they picked
her we shouted other stuff I thought it
was a stripper but maybe I could slip
her a tener yeah who's talking was it
you front row shouting Steven Haw that's
a great British guy he lingers another
thing picture those kings fingers King
Charles he used to be the prince then
rip Queen Lizzy went off the end ceased
to be and now he's there on the throne
and you saw he's grasping on his Lance
grasping on his orb with his massive
sausage Porky hands they're so small
still like William came out of his balls
he probably has Ed I know it's a sin is
it treason for me to say he takes him if
it is I apologize can't be beat I'd head
down fire die down there to Wall Street
I say me oh my who catches my eye he's
got a very nice suit that's a handsome
guy I walk up and I say Su look here
you're a gay of Wall Street you're my
favorite queer with the rainbow flag
LGBT we go home and we [__] bone to bone
to me bone to bone makes the sound of a
xylophone that's the thing we need leave
it all alone now the last one if you
feel shitty or vomity emissions and
you're 7even years old see a
pediatrician you need to go there yeah
it's meant to be Victorian Healthcare
and England centrally you get charged
with the dentry if you're feeling ill
don't [__] up and give them the hyns
wrong
[Applause]
pill
you guys are lovely thank you very much
my name is CH good night
goodbye